c'est hannachi de son rang ce celle-ci
ne le sont pas les composés qui causent
la rend si dit et il n'y a pas vraiment
de changement de couleur france rancy
dit et rancissement ça veut dire quoi
la rapidité c'est un défaut qu'on va
dire organoleptiques c'est-à-dire
sensorielle qui s'explique par plusieurs
processus gym et eric ayala et
spécialiste en chimie alimentaire
il reconnaît sans problème les aliments
france
aussi je vous apporter quelque chose qui
selon moi sont déserts h et de rance un
animal d oui disons que je pourrai
extraire l'huile puis fin lille pour
cirer des meubles l'art acidité va
principalement affecté les produits qui
sont riches en matières grasses donc
plus il ya des l'huile plus il ya des
gras insaturés c'est à dire les bons
gras pour la santé mais c'est cela qui
sont les plus susceptibles d'être
attaqués par l'oxygène et produire le
phénomène qu'on appelle la rend si tu es
donc les noix et les huiles mais aussi
des farines grain et certaines viandes
comme par exemple le poisson ou les
volailles
ça peut développer la rance dit et même
à court de congélation les boeufs qui
est beaucoup plus résistant parce qu'il
ya beaucoup moins d'acides gras
insaturés
l'ennemi numéro un de ces aliments c'est
le contact avec l'air ce qui compte la
rapidité c'est oui l'oxygène mais il ya
plusieurs facteurs qui vont rentrer en
bout de ligne par exemple la chaleur ça
va accélérer la présence ou le contact
avec des métaux aussi ça va déclencher
cette oxydation là et finalement
l'exposition à la lumière
votre meilleur allié pour détecter le
rancissement votre nez ou oh oui mais
seul ça c'est lui le remplacer la
vieille peinture peinture à l'huile
parmi les odeurs qu'on associe or ans
y'a que ça sent la peinture la peinture
à l'huile que ça sent le carton mouillé
la vieille noix ou la vieille friture
attention la rend si dit et n'a pas
qu'une seule odeur ici jeune gay n'est
propre ça c'est propre
oui mais je sais c'est pas ça à l'odeur
de rance
mais ça sent vraiment pas bon c'est une
grille de cuisine avec laquelle à un
moment donné on a nettoyé en dégage
huile et on la lave avec des savons
qu'ils ont pas nécessairement de parfum
et donc les produits d'oxydation des
restes et prennez dentition ça sent
vieux chalet fermé trop longtemps
deuxième outil de détection
votre goût un goût âcre confirmera votre
doute et nous il qu en plus qui errance
on devrait plus l'utiliser même pour
cuisiner parce que ça peut goûter et ça
va gâcher le goût de nos aliments mais
aussi parce que les points de fumée
diminue énormément et donc elle devient
plus susceptibles se défaire à se
dégrader lors de la cuisson
[Musique]
les gens s'en rend compte assez vite
quand c'est pas fréquent cérences
on le suit donc le corps est bien
aiguillé pour savoir si c'est pas bon à
manger
chez branagh tout est mis en place afin
de protéger des éléments durant six
manches pour éviter le gaspillage
alimentaire donc fallu choisir un
emballage qu'une bonne barrière à
l'oxygène pour éviter les pertes évitées
le rancissement donc on aussi un
agrégateur d'azov dans le fond c'est
qu'on enlève l'oxygène du sac et on
insuffle de la zone et la zac est un gaz
inerte qui ne réagit pas dans le fond
avec les acides gras et qui va vraiment
diminuer la vitesse de lancement de noix
et donc conserver leur qualité
à plus long terme air lumière métaux et
chaleur on a quelques indices pour
éviter ou ralentir le rancissement notre
responsabilité en tant que consommateur
c'est d'acheter des quantités
raisonnables et delek consommé dans un
temps raisonnable je la met dans un
bocal qui est étanche à l'air comme du
bas rhin aussi les garder à l'abri de la
lumière
ça c'est essentiel
il ya des noix qui sont très stables
témoin mes amants par exemple je les
achète en 50 livres les gars dans ma
cave offrait évidemment pas l'humidité
ça vous garder deux entendre sans
problème mais les noix je devrais plus
fragiles qui ont des hauts taux de gras
saturés comme le macadam grenoble à
quinze chambres fédérales un soc et des
graines mais j'aurais tendance si je les
consomme pas rapidement à les mettre
dans le frigo ou au congélateur acheté
en vrac ou en sac
le principe de conservation demeure le
même des fois en magasin ben c'est sous
la lumière cci des fois il fait plus
chaud leur climatisation fonctionne
potes un moment donné on peut pas tout
contrôler et si jamais je mangeais un
ami m'en rend si je m'en suis pas rendu
compte
est ce que ça peut être dangereux pour
ma santé de si on les a déjà mangé ya
aucun problème à fait l'exposition
occasionnels à des produits des rancy
dit et c'est normal ça arrive puis on
n'a pas vraiment des problèmes de santé
d'associations
j'ai toujours comparé aussi les aliments
à reims à des vins bouchonnés souvent il
faut que quelqu'un nous dise régal ça
c'est un aliment rend ce qu'on l'a
enregistre pour qu'après en plus
l'associé et plus on s'entraîne à
détecter la densité plus on devient
sensible
[Musique]